dude have a I don't know if you you
mighta saw how about your boy did I send
it to you be that the article on Nick
Cannon do you see them they can and
stuff I I did I didn't read your
wouldn't make say he seems like such a
nice guy I'm a huge Nick Cannon fan man
I think he's brilliant he's a smart goon
he look at what he's done you know with
his producer brain you know the guys
were a lot of money most stuff that he
does he own so for instant why that show
Wilin out that's been on MTV for 15
years he created and he'll it you know
it's a multi multi-million dollar
business for him and then he brings that
same he does a live tour of that in our
own nation so that that's a big
moneymaker for him so he did it what's
interested this podcast but he did it I
think he did it like a year ago you know
cuz he's so busy he so he hosts the
morning radio out here he's the voice of
105 nine Nick Cannon mornings and he
knows the masked singer that he's Wilin
out then he has his own syndicated talk
show supposed to come out to on CBS and
so he did this podcast it was a
wild-eyed a long time ago that months if
not a year ago and he came out these are
his words he was saying that blacks are
the real Hebrews and blacks are the real
Jews and that white people are last and
that white people are close to the
animal is this the pigment in their skin
so we're we're we're more prone to be
savages and all white people are evil
that's that's that's his in a nut job
what he was saying
bizarre for a guy not smart to say
something like that he's always made
comments you know but white people stuff
like that and you know it's it's
whatever the problem is is I know if I
come one to apologize and he didn't want
to apologize and then now he doubled
down on it and he he didn't issue an
apology today he basically was like well
if you know I tried meeting with thing
behind closed door and to dress me and
fill me on fill me in where I went wrong
and he goes in I didn't get response
from the CEO of Viacom and so he goes
give me my things at the hundred million
dollar value of wildin out
so how am i yeah I don't think he has a
hundred million but uh he's saying that
while a now it's worth that much
I don't listen i the one thing you don't
want to do is especially not even now
anytime you know me anti-semitic
especially what he was saying it's like
dude what benefit did you gain from
doing that man I don't think you should
be canceled I don't think she lost his
job I think people can learn especially
when you tell my guys Nick Cannon what
do you look at this full body of work
you know he's gonna doing it he's been
part of CBS Showtime CBS Viacom for 20
years
tipping hero be cancelled will flat
black on fire them eat so he he's that
so he no longer he can't be wiling out
um you know I can do the math singer you
know yeah they want him an apology any
double down well I don't I'm not sure if
that's why they fired of item over the
anti-semitic remarks that blacks are the
real juice that the real Hebrews not you
know it got dicey man that's a that's
funny because I'm I think Moses his
second wife Rebecca or whatever no admit
listen her name she was from Ethiopia so
there's this there is a there is the tie
between app black Africa and the Jews
from Israel has always been this sort of
meshing of the original you know Moses
being you know Jew and there's there's
always been this kind of like connection
yeah you gotta leave I'm sure katha
haven't curtilage yeah the real comments
when I read like a flop Nick and I like
him again I'm not with this cancelled
culture man I don't think people should
lose lose their livelihood lose their
entire careers you know based off one
comment I think you know you look at
Nick's body of work that's not suddenly
just forget about
years of now but there's a lot of it
there is this cancel culture and there
is no cancel I'm [ __ ] you know I mean
it's it's it's it over really ridiculous
things where people are losing their
jobs and and that's your livelihood and
it that is much worse than people can
match you spend 30 years building a
career 20 years building career and you
say some things that people don't agree
with I don't know what Nick can assess
I'm not even using him as an example
they're not you said he said some bed
yeah oh for sure much less but don't you
notice that this cancel culture and
these even these you know low level
comments who've never there that go
after other people don't you don't you
ever notice that it's never somebody
who's doing well in their career that
wants to cancel somebody else yeah
there's a common theme it's usually it's
usually a group you know people that
aren't happy with their lives who are
going after this person who has success
up here that's always you're doing it
behind the keyboard yes there are a lot
of people just enjoy destruction tell
you this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]